[Música]
el ser feliz aburrido
quien aquí disfruta el aburrimiento
puede levantar la mano
lo disfrutas ok no todos somos iguales
el aburrimiento de repente es necesario
cuando haces filas en el banco o cuando
vas en el tráfico y de hecho el
aburrimiento es bueno cuando te provoca
odiarlo para ser creativo
muchos de nosotros fuimos educados no en
esta era digital
en una era industrial
y no sé tú pero de niño que te digan que
el ser curioso mató a alguien
definitivamente infunde miedo
que nos digan que la curiosidad mató al
gato es sumamente horrible
y de hecho hay una cultura para inhibir
la curiosidad una cultura para inhibir
las preguntas acaso se puede ser feliz o
se puede aprender o podemos sentirnos
mismos aburridos yo creo que
definitivamente no lo podemos hacer
sin curiosidad la mente
yo no sé tú pero cuántas veces no te
fuiste con la idea en la escuela en tu
vida de que aprender era memorizar
o de que tratase de aprender con el
miedo a reprobar yo tengo una mala
noticia prácticamente todo lo que
estudiamos todo conocimiento toda
experiencia que viviste bajo el miedo no
te permitió aprender
por eso ahora repetir ya no es tener
experiencia
de hecho cuando tú repites mucho algo a
lo que le llamas experiencia y te
empiezas a aburrir tu mente te está
diciendo que ya no estás aprendiendo
esos peligros o sabes hay gente muy
orgullosa de llevar 10 años de
experiencia en algo cuando en realidad
son tres de experiencia y siete de
repetición
de hecho hay gente que hoy lleva la
mitad de tiempo que tú y yo haciendo lo
que tú y yo hacemos y sabe más que tú
que yo porque tienen un umbral de
aburrimiento bajo
hay un estudio de equipo que confirma
que una niña de 4 años en promedio
hace aproximadamente 300 preguntas
imagínate responder 300 preguntas al día
eso lo viven las mamás 300 preguntas al
día corresponde a más de 100 mil
preguntas al año
cómo lidiar con tantas preguntas y sabes
hay datos que demuestran que el promedio
de preguntas que le hace un adulto por
ejemplo a google es de 10 preguntas al
día y parece insuficiente no parece
mucho pero en realidad no es más del 4
por ciento de lo que hace un niño de 4
años una niña de 4 años por alguna razón
las niñas son más curiosas que los niños
a una pequeña edad de hecho las mejores
conexiones de tu vida las mejores ventas
los mejores negocios las mejores
conversaciones las han detonado la
formulación de grandes preguntas
y la curiosidad profesionalizar tu
curiosidad implica profesionalizarte en
hacer preguntas se dice que el que
pregunta manda yo estoy totalmente de
acuerdo con eso pero también yo digo que
el que provoca también pero necesitamos
es asociar que el provocar
necesariamente es malo podemos provocar
felicidad post provocar odio pero
también podemos provocar indiferencia
desconexión formular una pregunta es una
oportunidad de conectar con algo o con
alguien y sabes en muchos de los casos
cuando haces una pregunta no cuando le
tocas la curiosidad de las personas ni
siquiera importa la respuesta
no importa si es mala no importa si es
parcial no importa si es buena lo que
importa es que hay una reacción
hace unos años tuve la oportunidad de
estar con un director un directivo de
facebook nou
le preguntábamos oye realmente vale la
pena tener tantos likes tantos
seguidores en esta era de la red de las
redes sociales y él mismo decía en
realidad no importa cuánta gente te siga
lo que importa es cuánta gente reacciona
es impresionante pero muchos de nosotros
seguimos haciendo cosas planteando cosas
comunicando ideas hablando con gente que
no reacciona y no estoy diciendo que no
hablemos con que no reacciona pero
buscando o tolerando la no reacción y
perdiendo la oportunidad de afilar y
profesionalizar nuestras preguntas hay
buenas preguntas básicas no por ejemplo
a mí me ha sorprendido a mí me encantan
los nombres o los apellidos que no había
escuchado antes
qué significa tu nombre
lo pasé un poco me decía alguien bueno
que es tan común mi nombre que no me
interesa ningún significado no
qué significa tu apellido
de dónde viene a caso tendrás claridad
de saber a dónde ir si no sabes de dónde
vienes o por lo menos tener una
referencia no por algo existe un influye
en mí no una empresa que te permite ver
tus genes de dónde vienes
y que necesitarías aprender hoy que hace
evitaba aprender durante toda tu vida
hace poco vi un meme que me sorprendía
mucho que decía si tú no aprendiste de
tu relación con tu ex regresarás con tu
ex para toda tu vida en cuerpos
diferentes
esté dispuesto
pues muchos de nosotros lo hacemos
repetimos los mismos patrones que tal es
cuando ves algo que te detona curiosidad
y te tragas las preguntas sabes
culturalmente está mal ser preguntón
no parece rebeldía parece que quieres ir
en contra de lo contrario lo que quiere
romper reglas que ya están rotas
pero la ingenuidad que tiene un niño una
ingenuidad selectiva que tiene un niño
para hacer preguntas que incluso suenan
sumamente absurdas
abren la mente hace poco me decía una
niña me decía tiene invento adiós
contesta esa pregunta
porque el agua es mojada
cómo respondes eso
y otro día me preguntaba uno de mis
hijos cuantas hormigas habrá en el mundo
y bueno seguramente tú también has
desarrollado esa habilidad de sacar el
celular y buscar el google no sé cuántas
hormigas hay en el mundo lo que sí sé es
que hay más de 10.000 tipos de especies
10.000 tipos de hormigas en el mundo
guau no es el factor wow es el que
muchas veces tú y yo perdemos sabes
hace unos meses tuve la oportunidad de
empezar aa bucear
y conocí un maestro un maestro italiano
muy serio muy en su rol de maestro y él
contaba con una cicatriz de un lado a
otro yo no sé tú pero yo soy fan de las
cicatrices yo estoy convencido que
detrás de toda cicatriz hay una buena
historia puede ser muy ridícula y
absurda para y buenas historias
y me comentaba que él fue soldado de la
onu en kosovo y que iba caminando y que
siente un piquete su del lado derecho
y que se desmayó y me contaba que en
realidad fue que un francotirador le
había disparado a bajo el chaleco para
matarlo y no murió obviamente
pero me encantó escuchar esa historia
obviamente mi experiencia al bucear con
un ex soldado de la onu fue totalmente
diferente que con un simple maestro de
buceo por el simple hecho de preguntar
preguntas como me amas a un ser querido
pueden provocar en segundos lágrimas
lo que preguntas como qué porcentaje de
lo que podría saber vas a saber hoy
si has domesticado tu curiosidad
datos por ejemplo de ibm confirman que
el 90% de toda la información que hoy
existe no existía hace dos años
sin duda hay más por conocer de lo que
ya conoce
sin embargo tenemos que tener claridad
que hay una crisis de atención la gente
dice es que ya no hay atención la gente
ya no pone atención en realidad tenemos
la misma atención de siempre
pero antes la teníamos en bloques luego
en ladrillos después en piezas de lego
hoy tenemos atención en pequeñas
partículas en pequeños pixeles
imagínate que hoy tienes la misma
atención que tenían sus ancestros antes
antepasados pero ahora son unidades cada
vez más pequeñas y si yo quiero tu
atención me vas a dar esas pastillas
pequeñas de atención hay una crisis de
atención que detona desconexión de hecho
la tolerancia para conectar con una
persona es de segundos lo estamos viendo
en internet el gran espejo humano la
tolerancia para que una persona entre
una página y conecta y entiendan lo que
está haciendo es de dos a tres segundos
sucede que tenemos poco tiempo para
conectar con las personas y estamos en
una era que es más fácil conectar con el
wifi que con la gente
y la curiosidad es una excelente
herramienta para contrarrestar pues esta
desconexión ayma drones de curiosidad
sabes yo tengo identificado
aproximadamente unos tres o cuatro el
primero es generalizar
qué pensarías tú si yo te dijera que
todos los regios son iguales realmente
no te gustaría pero qué pasaría si tú me
dijeras todas las de la ciudad de mexico
son iguales seguramente a mí no me
gustaría cuando generalizamos asesinamos
nuestra curiosidad porque etiquetamos
metemos a todos en un mismo cajón
no tienes esa necesidad o esa capacidad
de asombro para poder leer identificar a
la gente
cuántas veces el generalizar te evitado
encontrar la belleza de lo peculiar de
las personas de los problemas y de los
lugares otro ladrón de la curiosidad es
la superficialidad colectiva cuantos no
hemos visto esta tendencia en los fake
news no te cuento una historia yo yo me
cansé de ver pig no perdón lo que
voy a decir me cansé de depender
navegando en internet encuentre una nota
que dice neurocientíficos descubren que
pig lastima el cerebro de los niños
y yo si la comparto me crucifican un
buen de mamas y de personas y me pongo a
estudiar el artículo y era fake según un
maestro universitario de harvard decía
lo busque no existía lo borré
cuántos de nosotros no hemos sido
superficiales de forma colectiva y
hablamos de temas que ni siquiera leímos
no leemos la nota ni siquiera estuvimos
de forma presencial y compartimos el
tema llenando los vacíos tercero lo
urgente vivimos una cultura de lo
urgente donde todo tiene que pasar
rápido
y sabes que la urgencia es apremiante
nivel química no a nivel química en tu
mente pero en realidad cuando estás bajo
el urgente nada es importante y bajo lo
urgente sólo te queda reaccionar y
reaccionar no es pensar
reaccionar no te hace inteligente de
hecho es todo lo contrario
de hecho si yo puedo provocarte
reaccionar yo te defino y te lo decía
anteriormente reaccionar y vivir bajo el
urgente te hace totalmente vulnerable
tiene toda la curiosidad bueno hay
varios detonadores el primero algo que
yo le llamo ingenuidad selectiva
el creer en la gente es importante de
forma selectiva creer que puede haber
algo diferente aunque haya muchas cosas
similares y tener claro que aunque hay
generalidades casi todas las
generalidades en realidad son peculiares
o particulares
también algo que debemos de aprovechar
para detonar nuestra curiosidad es algo
que yo le llamo inteligencia kloster
inteligencia clúster y se dice que una
cualidad de una inteligencia elevada
radica en aceptar dos realidades que se
oponen y estar de acuerdo con ello
y pasa mucho cuando hablamos primero
temas de política este político es bueno
o malo
de hecho pensar en bueno y malo es
sumamente limitado hay muchos más
ángulos pero cuántas veces no
polarizamos nuestra forma de pensar
blanco y negro abajo de arriba esquina
derecha
pero hay muchos más ángulos hay muchas
más opciones la inteligencia kloster
radica en reconocer que hay realidades
que se oponen y está bien con ello y
tienes que aceptarlo como un pensamiento
más holístico no también tienes que
tener cierta rebeldía no ser un poco
anárquico para romper el status quo y
sabes hay un estudio de un doctor que me
michelle spence-jones
que tiene un ph de la universidad de
portland que dice que convivir con niños
fomenta tu inteligencia fomenta tu
capacidad de asombro y te permite ser
más curioso
convivir con niños te ayuda a ser más
curioso también conocer gente diferente
a ti y sabes es sorprendente cuando solo
queremos conocer gente parecidas a
nosotros mismos porque queremos evitar
el estar incómodo que nos incomoda
alguien no es y te empiezas a blindar y
ayudar de gente que piensa como tú sabes
que te aburres lo que ha pasado de hecho
hay gente más talentosa y más
inteligente que tuvo hay muchos tipos de
inteligencia de 8 hasta 32 tipos de
inteligencia que deben de
complementarnos viajar también te abre
la mente para tener nuevos ángulos y
bueno el miedo impide aprender casi todo
lo que hemos hecho en la vida bajo el
miedo es una reacción no aprendimos y
según la neurociencia pues eso es una
pérdida de tiempo hoy en día hay que
reconocer que la curiosidad y el miedo
no pueden coexistir en realidad el miedo
sólo nos lleva a sobrevivir y hay muchos
tipos de curiosidad sabes no hay una
curiosidad que le llama el morbo que es
el lado oscuro de la curiosidad que es
egoísta no es lo que radicado detone el
chisme y no crucial neutral no que es la
curiosidad
de alguna forma domesticada existen lo
que yo le llamo hiper curiosidad oa lo
que es nombrado como curioso
que te convierte en una autodidacta la
curiosidad
que te impide aburrirte en la rutina la
que te permite y te regala el poder
equivocarte rápido aprender rápido
desaprender rápido y re aprender rápido
la curiosidad
yo no apuesto a que si fomentamos la
cultura de la curiosidad podemos ser
mejores personas podemos conectar con
nuevas personas podemos no etiquetar a
las personas podemos conocer ángulos
únicos irrepetibles que nadie más conoce
hace unos años fui a san francisco a una
expo en busca de innovación y me dio a
mi padre
y conocí a un chino que representaba una
empresa de medios en china
cuando empecé a negociar con este chino
no esta persona para hacer negocios en
latinoamérica le dije yo quiero
representar su plataforma en
latinoamérica y me dijo tú eres
honorable porque llevas a tu papá a las
expos
y me dijo ay si fallo in your eyes yo
veo fuego en tus ojos archivos y le digo
es que quiero representar tu plataforma
y latinoamérica me dice ya la
representas
y eso me abrió al negocio más grande de
mi vida
el llevar a mi papá y no maconí porque
lo lleve sabes
pero funcionó
es por eso que también requerimos del
factor random no aleatorio no tú puedes
ser lineal y planeado se puede provocar
curiosidad sin cubrir sin ser curioso no
puedes un ser aburrido no puede provocar
curiosidad solo puede provocarle a
alguien curioso
y sabes aprendes a no desarrollar
aprendes a desarrollar un rechazo al no
saber las cosas si puedes saber algo es
por algo no y digo no puedes saber todo
no te vuelves loco pero puedes saber lo
más importante y empieza a desarrollar
una pasión en tu plexo solar por
capitalizar aterrizar concretar tu
curiosidad profesionalizar tu curiosidad
implica recuperar ese científico y qué
llevas dentro que todo el niño lo tiene
dentro
incluye recuperar tu capacidad de
asombro observar a los demás observante
a ti mismo observar tus pensamientos y
más que juzgar entender el porqué de las
cosas hoy en día la ignorancia es una
decisión voluntaria recupera tu
curiosidad gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]